this episode of the y-files is brought
to you by pdsdet
the night after Christmas 1980 was the
last time Airman First Class John
Burroughs would ever lead a normal life
he was on patrol at American operated
Woodbridge Air Force Base in Southern
England Woodbridge and nearby bent
Waters called the twin bases were
rumored to possess nuclear materials
this was the middle of the Cold War and
tensions were high
threat of nuclear attack Global
escalation and more sat heavy on the
shoulders of Burroughs and his fellow
servicemen but their job was simple keep
themselves their nation and their allies
safe
so Burrows conducted his nightly rounds
checking the perimeter for anything that
threatened the peace suddenly a bright
light descended from the sky and then
another Burroughs watched as the lights
fell into the forest surrounding the
base when he and his team arrived to
inspect the crash site they were worried
it was a Soviet incursion but what they
found was far more terrifying than
Soviets
[Music]
you got to be kidding me human
there are so many things in that
statement
spoke camel van it means custom-made I
know what bespoke means
important it is to pay these guys on
time so chop chop with the bread Jack
why are you buying a custom camel van
and why do you need my power washer why
do you need my power washer back then
why do you need it
all right all right look everything is
so expensive right now and I pay my
bills every month and it doesn't even
make a dent so I needed it I needed a
side gig which I wouldn't need if you
gave me a raise but no you guys I can
hear you but I'd come up with a great
business idea oh this is gonna be good
yeah I'm starting a mobile camera
grooming service I'm calling it
pump and brush
while I give you the cleanest hump in
town after I finish you'll smell great
yeah
um I know I'm gonna
so the power washer
washer look I'm not coughing up anything
will you just call PDS and have them
take care of your debt so you can be
here doing your actual job
[Music]
yes why yes
yes it is they have options for anyone
struggling with a lot of monthly debt
payments credit cards personal loans
collections medical bills everyone with
over ten thousand dollars or more
ineligible debt qualifies uh but my
credit
dirty camel there's no minimum credit
score required bad and Fair Credit is
accepted they roll your debt into one
low zero percent interest monthly
payment you can save thousands in
interest and fees and pay off your debt
in a fraction of the time it sounds
perfect and PDS is giving our qualified
viewers a free debt analysis just for
completing the 30-second online
assessment at
www.pdsdebt.com files and it's
pdsdebt.com you got it okay I'm going in
now but I'm still gonna send gertio up
for the power washing at this show she
needs a bath and she doesn't fit in my
tub no oh you had that walk-in shower
that's even better just make sure you
scrub really good behind your ears she
really likes that she said make you
happy to give you a bath he's a naughty
little hump scrubber do not send her
here I'm not gonna wash your camel
mmm
it all started around 3 A.M on December
26 1980. U.S Airmen first class John
Burroughs and staff sergeant Bud stefans
were on patrol near the east gate at the
Woodbridge base it was a slow night but
soon they felt uneasy there was static
electricity in the air suddenly a light
descended from the sky into rendersham
Forest Landing about half a mile from
the end of the base's main Runway and
then another light the lights were
flashing red and blue green and yellow
on and off and at first they thought it
must be a downed aircraft but no one
heard a crash there was no sound of any
kind
Burroughs and Stefan called in the
situation from the guard shack they
didn't want anyone to hear their report
on an unsecure radio just in case the
crash needed to be dealt with quietly
remember this was the Cold War and the
servicemen weren't sure what they were
dealing with yet staff sergeant Jim
peniston was the on-duty flight Chief at
Woodbridge he grabbed Airmen Edward
cabansag and they headed to the east
gate to get a clear picture of the
situation all four men agreed that the
lights must have been a downed aircraft
but why didn't it make a sound something
so close to the twin bases would have
alerted plenty of personnel it would
have been impossible to miss they
checked in with both bases nobody at
Woodbridge or bentwater saw or heard
anything they called RAF bodzie they
called RAF Watton they even checked in
with Heathrow Airport to see if anyone
reported a downed aircraft in the area
nothing but something strange did show
up on radar about 15 minutes before the
lights fell into rentals from forest a
radar operator reported a bogey
Humphrey Bogut a bogey is an unknown
aircraft
that makes more sense
the bogey was lost from radar directly
over the base
then orders came down go check it out
the four men drove out to the east gate
and down a public road mostly used for
logging and hiking the road connected to
a trail that led deeper inside the
forest toward the crash but as soon as
they hit the trail their communication
equipment started to malfunction it was
like a Jammer or something interfering
with the frequencies the radio still
worked but only over very short
distances anything farther than a few
feet was nothing but static now in the
distance they could hear farm animals
going crazy all around them wild animals
sounded like they were screaming
screaming like humans
[Applause]
ah
and they admitted this terrified them
and all the time they'd lived in and
around twin bases they'd never heard
anything like this they kept walking for
a few minutes before They Came Upon a
small clearing and as soon as they
stepped out of the trees an explosion of
light hit them the light was blinding
even though it was the middle of the
night the area was lit up like the day
they shielded their eyes and finally saw
the source of the light it was coming
from a craft
triangular shaped craft made no sound
and when the men took a step toward it
the animals stopped screaming Clarice
have the land stop screaming you want me
to tell the story or not sorry I
couldn't help it the feeling of
electricity was now everywhere peniston
said he could feel it on his skin he
rubs the lotion on its skin or else it
gets the hose again
when peniston got closer he saw symbols
that look like hieroglyphics engraved on
the side he ran his hand along the
exterior of the craft the metal was
smooth and warm to the touch the symbols
whatever they were felt like sandpaper
as peniston drew his hand away
everything went bright white it took a
second for his vision to return and when
it did he grabbed his notebook and wrote
down as many details as possible
including diagrams after a few minutes
the craft slowly started to lift into
the sky still silent it took two or
three minutes to clear the tree level
peniston wrote about the liftoff in his
notebook I estimated it to be about
three meters tall and about three meters
wide at the base no landing gear was
apparent but it seemed like she was on
fixed legs I moved a little closer I
walked around the craft and finally I
walked right up to the craft I noticed
the fabric of the shell was more like a
smooth opaque black glass
where the craft had landed they saw a
few indentations in the ground but not
much else as they made their way back to
the others pennison made the comment
that the experience lasted a few minutes
Burrows stopped confused for him it was
only a few seconds and that was weird
they finally got to the end of the trail
but everybody was gone cabinsag Chandler
and six other military personnel were
all the way back on the road and in a
state of panic in the commotion someone
radioed Woodbridge to report Burrows and
peniston were found safe and Alive they
could call off the search parties search
party yeah peniston and Burrows didn't
understand they were just a short walk
down the path and they were out of
contact for just a few minutes
that's not what everyone else
experienced
when Burrows and peniston disappeared
into the forest they were gone for
almost 45 minutes
then peniston felt dizzy and uneasy on
his feet and though he didn't admit it
at the time this is when the vision
started
records show the American Military
called British authorities on December
26th an hour after the first sighting at
4 AM local police were called to the
location but the only lights they could
see were from the Orford Nest Lighthouse
a few miles away
we have a sighting of someone who
unusual lights
around 5am Deputy based Commander
Lieutenant Colonel Charles I halt
arrived on the scene halt was 41 years
old at the time and had served in
Vietnam and Korea he had no time for UFO
stories and was annoyed that his men
were getting distracted by such nonsense
and believing this was all nonsense halt
ordered a staff sergeant to add
information to the ship's logs using
vague terminology but it didn't matter
what was written in the logs by the
early morning it seemed like everyone
knew a UFO had landed nearby during the
night before Daybreak a group of men
went back to the site to take
measurements and photographs the three
indentations peniston and burro saw were
still there it was the middle of winter
and the ground was frozen solid so
whatever created these indentations must
have been incredibly heavy once they
were done gathering information the men
returned to base and went about their
business peniston drove home and tried
to catch up on sleep but he couldn't
relax he felt compelled to go back to
the landing site like his entire body
was telling him to return so he did
pennison brought plaster of Paris to
take a mold of the indentations of the
landing marks he wanted physical proof
of what happened to him so he can prove
to himself that he wasn't crazy
the rest of December 26th was uneventful
as was most of December 27th but that
evening the base had its annual Awards
dinner and most of the officers were in
attendance including Colonel halt in the
middle of the event the on-duty shift
Commander burst through the door his
face was pale and he looked like he was
in shock he made a beeline for halt and
whispered sir
it's back
halt assembled a team to investigate the
men gathered handheld cassette recorders
cameras and even a geiger counter to
measure radiation Hall was known for
carrying a tape recorder wherever he
went and recorded the investigation in
real time
when they got to The Landing site the
three indentations in the ground were
the craft allegedly landed were throwing
off radiation
trees around the site were discolored
and there were odd abrasions on the
trunks
hey
Paul ordered samples from the trees to
be taken for analysis but the team had
to be careful the trees were also
throwing off radiation
and viewing the scene through thermal
imaging showed that the trees and
landing area were warmer than the rest
of the environment
you aren't getting an indication of a
heat Source coming out of that satisfied
and just before 2 am something spooked
the animals of rendersham forest again
[Music]
a small red light appeared between the
trees and the Animals fell silent and it
was deathly calm the red light hovered
over the clearing it started to move
through the trees so Halt and a few
others followed it
this is weird
now two lights appeared both shooting
off yellow Sparks and they moved back
and forth like a blinking eye
twice in the sky
there's
and then things got intense you can hear
halt crying out on the tape that a beam
of light just struck the ground 10 feet
in front of his team
are coming down to the ground
the light was described like a laser it
wasn't damaging anything but the men got
the impression that it was scanning for
something now we still don't know if
there were nuclear weapons stored at
Twin bases but this would only be one of
many UFO encounters at a nuclear
facility local police were also busy
responding to reports of strange lights
all over the county but as quickly as
they showed up the Rendell shim UFOs
were gone the witnesses had no answers
they were left with only questions
but they were left with more than that
I was very skeptical I found what had
allegedly taken place hard to believe
[Applause]
and as events unfolded I became more and
more concerned that there may be
something to this I kept telling myself
that there had to be some type of an
explanation for it but I certainly
couldn't find one even to this day I I
can't explain what happened
in the months after the incident
Burroughs peniston and others started
experiencing health problems Burrow's
eyes were deteriorating he had throat
issues he developed a heart condition
years later a specialist told Burrows
that his symptoms are usually found in
people exposed to high levels of
radiation now Burroughs remembered the
high radiation readings in rendelson
Forest he requested his medical records
from the Air Force but the request was
refused and this was years after he
retired from service and at one point
the military wouldn't even admit the
boroughs had served all information on
him was considered top secret doctors
later identified the cause of burrows
injuries as Broadband non-ionizing
electromagnetic radiation now this could
occur if you're exposed to ultraviolet
infrared or high-powered microwave
energy the military now had no choice
but to acknowledge the situation
the US government finally admitted that
the servicemen suffered serious health
problems and a few of them were even
granted medical disability but many of
Burroughs medical records are still
classified to this day
Sergeant Jim pennison also experienced
after effects from the UFO encounter now
he was never the same after that flash
of white light he saw while touching the
craft and that night when he was going
over his notes and diagrams he started
to feel sick and then he had visions of
ones and zeros he had no idea what they
meant or what was happening to him but
the numbers were so vivid he started
writing them down and the more he wrote
the better he felt then finally the
vision stopped Jim put his notebook away
and didn't think about it again for
another 30 years he completely forgotten
about writing down all those ones and
zeros but in 2010 he pulled out his
notebook for an interview he wanted to
show the symbols that he saw on the
craft
as he was thumbing through the notebook
he came across the pages with the
numbers the interviewer said wait what's
that and Jim peniston was nonchalant
about it he said oh that was information
downloaded to me from the UFO Jim was
asked if it was binary code but he
didn't know what that was so they sent
the numbers to a computer expert to see
if there was anything to it now they
didn't tell the computer guy anything
they just said here are a bunch of
numbers tell us what you think
the tech couldn't believe it it was a
message
from the future
[Music]
for 30 years Jim peniston had a binary
message transmitted to his brain from a
UFO and he didn't know it
this is what it said
exploration of humanity continuous
continuous for planetary Advance eyes of
our eyes origin year 8100
and if that doesn't blow your mind how
about this the rest of the message is a
list of coordinates for locations all
over the planet
caracal Brazil
Sedona Arizona
the Great Pyramid of Giza
the Nazca Lines in Peru
mount taishan in China
the Temple of Apollo in Greece
and this final location is labeled the
origin wait what in the middle of the
ocean yes but this location might not
have always been ocean there is a
mythical island called high Brazil that
was allegedly here at one time high
Brazil is a phantom Island which is an
island that appears on maps for a period
of time but is later found to not exist
High Brazil appeared on maps for
hundreds of years including the famous
pure Reese map which was based on much
much older Maps researchers and
archaeologists have searched extensively
for the island and there is evidence
that Islands once existed there shallow
water shelves have been found at
porcupine Bank Northwest of Ireland and
similar shelves were discovered at Rock
Hall further north
all of the locations in the binary code
are known as highly spiritual places but
they've also been called portals to
other dimensions or to other planes of
reality because of this Jim peniston
doesn't think the rendelsham UFO was
extraterrestrial he thinks it was us he
thinks this was a message from humans
from 6 000 years in the future and
that's becoming a more common theory
regarding the recent UFO activity and
I've noticed that NASA is being very
cute about their explanations they said
just this week that there's no evidence
that any uaps are extraterrestrial in
origin but they still don't know what
they are to me that sounds like NASA
thinks it's possible that the uaps are
not from another planet but from this
planet now maybe an ancient race of
humanoids have existed here for
thousands or millions of years and now
they're making themselves known or maybe
like Jim peniston believes were being
visited by our future selves
the big question is why why now it feels
like they're trying to warn us of
something and because UFOs seem to be
very interested in what we're doing to
the planet and extremely interested in
what we're doing with nuclear technology
the warning is pretty serious so let's
hope these UFOs really are from outer
space because then they're warning us of
a disaster that could happen if the
warnings are from us in the future then
whatever disaster they're afraid of it's
already happened and considering what's
going on in the world right now I don't
think there's any way to stop it
[Music]
physical evidence audio recordings
countless high-ranking U.S military
Witnesses the rendersham forest UFO
incident has it all
but is any of it true well the answer
like in many UFO cases is it's
complicated so let's start with the big
picture are there official records of an
unknown object in rendersham Forest on
December 26th and December 28 1980 yes
is there evidence from the original
investigation corroborating the UFO
story
yes but there are issues there's a
discrepancy over the date of the first
sighting all of the official witness
statements say the lights first appeared
on December 26th except one peniston's
statement is undated and both he and
Hulk wrote independently the date of the
first sighting was actually December
27th the following night halt didn't
even file an official statement with the
military he wrote a memo on January 13
1981 after taking statements from
peniston Burroughs kabansag Chandler and
others but some of the witnesses said
their statements were Rewritten and they
were forced to sign in borough's witness
statement he said the light came from
the nearby Lighthouse and that's that
commandsex statement says the same thing
the orfordness lighthouse is visible
from The Landing site on the Eastern
edge of renderson forest the exact
Direction the men saw the lights the
blue and red lights well Burrows said it
was probably just local police checking
out the scene peniston is the only
witness who claimed to encounter the
craft he said he got within 50 meters of
it but it flew back every time he got
closer and later that story changed
peniston is the only one who reported
missing time and he didn't report this
until years later and only after he went
through regression hypnosis in 1994. hey
I'm not sure if regression hypnosis is
finding lost memories or creating new
ones whoa it's all right sweetheart what
is it oh there's like 20 of them it was
during hypnosis when the details about
touching the craft and the symbols got
added to the story peniston and Burrows
both have changed their stories a lot
over the years there was a very strange
feeling in the air Colonel halt is
always portrayed as this by the book
hard-nosed military commander but there
are questions about him too halt is
quoted as saying during debriefing
witnesses to the rendersham UFO incident
were subjected to mind control efforts
using drugs and hypnosis by the British
and American authorities now no one else
makes this claim and it wasn't mentioned
until years later a lot of data halt
said existed no longer does well a lot
of people say that and it could be but
halt's famous audio recordings are in
his possession and he says he's got the
whole night four or five hours on tape
but he's only released 18 minutes of
audio and those 18 minutes are edited he
refuses to release anything else
a pennison's notebook is also a problem
other Witnesses say there's no way he
could have written anything down he
wasn't at the site long enough the notes
also don't line up with the other
witness statements even the date is
wrong now there are plenty of details
and witness statements that do line up
but a lot of those can be explained halt
said the reddish yellow light he saw
through the trees would appear every
five seconds now we can hear this on the
tape but the light from the lighthouse
was visible through the trees and it was
set for a five second rotation cabansag
also mentioned this pulsing light but
the light he saw was confirmed to be the
lighthouse
whenever the rendelstrom story comes up
we only hear from the witnesses who
confirm the story as true rarely do we
hear from the many witnesses who claim
there were no UFOs but those Witnesses
do exist and they too have given sworn
statements there was absolutely nothing
in the woods we could see lights in the
distance and it appeared unusual as it
was a sweeping light contrary to what
some people assert at the time almost
none of us knew there was a lighthouse
at orfordness
remember the vast majority of folks
involved were young people 19 20 25
years old that's one reason the lights
appeared interesting or out of the
ordinary to some people
government Shield maybe the marks in the
trees were confirmed to be Hatchet marks
indicating to Foresters which trees to
cut down the high levels of radiation
actually weren't high at all even the
highest readings were within the normal
range for background radiation the
indentations in the ground weren't all
that deep locals say they were made by
animals now speaking of animals the
screaming in the forest is a creepy
detail of the story but it was probably
a deer oh it did scream Munchak deer do
yeah on a dark cold night in December
when you think you're chasing a UFO
hearing that sound from the woods would
be terrifying but these deer live in
rendlesham Forest the locals heard them
all the time but we don't have these in
the U.S and remember even though this
event happened in England all the
witnesses were American
in 2018 former members of the SAS
British Special Forces said the whole
thing was a prank in 1980 SAS had tested
the security of the base by parachuting
in they got caught remember this was
potentially a nuclear base this was the
hot row here
where weapons were stored in the ATF for
our team facility down there so the
British paratroopers were roughed up and
interrogated for 18 hours to make sure
this wasn't a Soviet ruse the British
soldiers didn't report the incident
which is not surprising competition
between Military Allies is always fierce
but you don't rat on fellow soldiers
but the SAS got their Revenge they said
they staged the whole incident and it
got out of hand now this seems like a
good explanation but I still can't find
any actual names there are a lot of
anonymous sources but the British
couldn't beam computer code into this
guy's brain Tennyson right there are
lots of problems with that notebook and
the whole binary code story he said he
forgot about the code and only
remembered it in 2010 during a
documentary shoot but you can see him
flipping through the notebook on TV as
early as 2003. now I guess he only
flipped halfway through the notebook and
then was like yeah I'm good
now suddenly in 2010 during another
presumably paid TV gig now there's
binary code and it's code that
translates into English and I always
have a problem with aliens sending code
in English it seems too specific and
unlikely I prefer when they communicate
with math like in the movie contact okay
101 the pulse sequence through every
prime number between 2 and 101 but some
people say they speak English because
they know that's what we understand fine
I guess
the binary code was ASCII encoded ASCII
is an American standard for encoding
text it existed in 1980 but it wasn't
commonly used plus the ASCII character
set has gone through multiple changes
over the years when this code was
downloaded into peniston's brain the
standard was 7 bits but the message
wasn't coded using 8 Bits which was the
standard but years later
a bunch of people with no
with no that's true they would
people who translated the code they took
some liberties
[Music]
they said it was this
but it actually translates to this
fragments of words no coordinates
[Music]
we need more pizza whatever
hey I'm trying work with me here and
remember how peniston sees a flash of
light goes into a little bit of a trance
and then has this binary code suddenly
in his head yeah well that's the exact
plot from an X-Files episode oh no the
episode is called conduit and aired in
1993. many years before peniston said
anything about binary code oh I'm really
annoyed right now yeah there are a lot
of problems with the rendersham story
now when you consider how many people
were involved in the incident it was
always going to be impossible to know
the truth everyone has their own version
of events whether we like it or not
that's human nature those who are
pro-ufo use the many high-ranking
military eyewitnesses as proof and
ignore all the conflicting evidence any
evidence that's missing well it's a
cover-up and those who are anti-ufo just
see the data attempting to debunk the
incident and they consider nothing else
valid the truth is probably somewhere in
the middle
and there is another possibility that
the rendelshim UFO incident could have
been part of a counterintelligence
operation
government disinformation is one of the
most frustrating parts of UFO research
counterintelligence officers like former
Air Force OSI agent Richard Doty insert
themselves into events like the one in
rendlesham Forest then they spread just
enough chaos rumors and crazy to confuse
a situation and Dodie openly admits it
was his job to lead the public away from
the truth to discredit the reputations
of those involved and ensure that even
true information is met with skepticism
in the early 1980s the Air Force was
ramping up UFO disinformation campaigns
and Dodie was a big part of that
whistleblower David grush has suddenly
appeared now that UFOs are mainstream
news but remember he also worked in the
Air Force as a Counter Intelligence
officer and everything he says publicly
is approved by the Pentagon first and
because of how successful
counterintelligence operations are at
covering up real events will likely
never know the full truth about the
rendelsham UFO incident but that doesn't
mean we shouldn't stop looking and when
Military Intelligence whistleblowers
show up I'm skeptical but I also want to
hear them out because contrary to what
the military thinks they're not smarter
than we are their house of cards is
built with lies and it only takes one
piece of evidence one witness or one
mistake and the whole thing comes
crashing down and me
I can't wait
thanks so much for hanging out with us
today my name is AJ that's Heckle fish
zero one one zero one zero zero zero
zero one one zero one zero zero one
in the Y files if you had fun or learned
anything do him a favor like subscribe
comment share that stuff really helps
the channel and like most topics we
cover on the channel today's was
recommended by you bye lots of you so if
there's a story you'd like to see or
learn more about go to the yfiles.com
tips and don't forget to check out the
why files Discord there's tons of people
on there 24 7 brother y files Gino is on
there right now getting weird stories
from fans so go check it out to White
files Discord it's free to join and it's
a lot of fun a special thanks to our
patrons who make this channel possible
you guys are so generous and I couldn't
do this without you I dedicate every
episode to you and if you'd like to
support the channel consider becoming a
member on patreon for as little as three
bucks a month you get all kinds of perks
like early access to videos without
commercials Early Access to products
like the hecklefish plushie plus you get
two extra live streams just for you
another great way to support is buy
something from the Wi-Fi store
[Music]
that's gonna do it until next time be
safe be kind and know that you are
appreciated
[Music]
51 a secret code inside the Bible said I
was
sure
[Music]
but then another conspiracy theory
becomes the truth my friends and it
never ends
[Music]
away
Stanley Kubrick fake the moon landing
alone on a film shed I wore the Shadows
[Music]
and his name was cold
with the
ES
[Music]
The Secret City Underground
foreign
[Music]
oh
yeah
[Music]
love to dance